we turn to some other news now a local  woman accused of killing her stepson  went before a judge this morning for the  first time  29 year old patricia adelig was in court  today for a status check  after she was arrested on friday metro  police say the four-year-old is marcel  foster jr you see him here they say his  father left him home without a leg while  he was at work  he came home to find the boy  unresponsive now according to the arrest  report a witness said adelaide got upset  when the little boy refused to eat his  lunch and was disrespectful to her he  said marcel was taken to a bedroom where  he could hear the boy being spanked and  what sounded like the child  falling to the floor